the migrant surge is overwhelming the
Health Department - more than 52,000
unaccompanied minors have been referred
to HHS this year and that's up 60%
compared to 2018
Omar Villafranca is at another facility
that we've been covering this one in
Clint Texas and it now faces a new
lawsuit alleging unsanitary conditions
Omar good morning to you I know you got
a tour of the building the question now
is what did you see well good morning
immigration lawyers who toured this
facility last week describe children
living here for weeks
in unsanitary conditions based on our
tour yesterday that did not match up
with those descriptions but keep in mind
this was a controlled guided tour we
were not allowed to take cameras inside
no cell phones and we were not allowed
to speak to children we saw a full
facility 117 children in the building
that was only meant to house 106 we were
also shown food crates clothing and the
toiletry supplies now yesterday the
lawyers who recently toured this
facility filed a lawsuit accusing the
Trump administration of endangering
these children one twelve-year-old boy
told the lawyers quote I'm so hungry
that I have woken up in the middle of
the night with hunger another a 16 year
old girl told them quote the day after
we arrived here my baby began vomiting
and having diarrhea I asked to see a
doctor and they did not take us now CVP
has not returned our request for a
comment but they have said in the past
they are overcrowded and they are
overwhelmed in these facilities
meanwhile CBS News has confirmed that
the Homeland Security Inspector General
is expected to release the results of an
investigation that calls some of these
situations here at the facilities
dangerous Anthony Omar thank you